Film Courage : Did you really move to New York City
with $60 in your pocket? Dui Jarrod, Filmmaker/Actor/Writer: I did all the
new words I would in New York with 60
bucks and two bags and I just knew that
I wanted to become a better writer and I
was totally disappointed and
disenfranchised by my feature film and
how that went so I was like I'm just
gonna go there and I'm gonna just be a
great writer and a friend of mine I had
an extra room in his house and so I
stayed in his extra room and not to
maybe like a year later I had enough
money to get my own place
what we're in the two bags I needed to
throw away they had holes on the side of
them the tread was worn down on them but
because those are the shoes that I had
carried through my journey I just never
wanted to get rid of them so they took
me forever to get rid of those Pullman's
way yeah they were they were in one of
those two bags I have something like
that too and it is it's a reminder
mm-hmm
it is it there's a history behind it
yeah yeah where you been
you don't want to forget it you don't
have again what you've been and how did
you travel did you travel by plane for
the flight one of my really good friends
like it was my time they kind of wound
down in Atlanta would have where I
produced my project and I needed to get
I needed a place to stay essentially I
mean you hate to say you homeless
but essentially it's true I'm not an a
police or money to get anything and a
friend of mine he got a ticket for him
he said yeah I have an extra bedroom out
here in New York you work on the same
and I went up there and I stayed in this
place and quickly found a job and just
tried to do what I needed to do to get
my life back on track
what was that time like in the airport
while you were waiting for the flight
and checking in I knew it was the right
move when I was in an airport headed to
New York I knew it was the right move
but I didn't know why I was had always
thought I would one day live in New York
I had made a single plan in my life to
move to New York and I just remember
getting to LaGuardia and literally
stepping off the plane and I knew that's
what I was supposed to be nothing
nothing in me said otherwise I knew that
I was supposed to be there was a film
festival and a film was that any part of
the motivation moving to New York
yes I had done a feature film called
let's look for love and I have put so
much work time and effort into this
feature and this was a con in the
beginning when Ava Duvernay had done a
middle of nowhere and she had done I
will follow so you started seeing like
Dee Ruiz doing these movies there were
all these micro budget black films that
were like getting attention
barry jenkins had just done medicine for
melancholy so i'm thinking like all i
have to do all i have to do is make a
film and if i make a film
it'll be significant enough for
hollywood's to come calling but i made
this film I got into this incredible
Film Festival out in Hollywood and I
just knew something would manifest I
just knew it and nothing happened
nothing happened and I just had my film
and all these dreams and they were just
sitting there
and I was like nothing's happening for
me in Atlanta my money is trying uh I
need to just be better for myself and I
thought what was wrong was I wasn't as
strong of a writer that's what I needed
to be and so that's why I decided to go
to New York is unlike the best writers
are writing theater right there in New
York so I went there to just absorb and
learn and grow and how long had it been
since you had finished that film it was
the same year it was the same year so I
did the film in 2000 at the very
beginning of 2011 and then went on the
film festival circuit I only got into
like four festivals I only had enough
money to submit for those boards oh hey
but um yeah got it to those festivals
and just thought like everything would
change and nothing nothing changed
nothing at all changed and it went from
being what I thought was gonna be my
calling card to like just another
project and I didn't know that you just
have to keep doing
next project and not necessarily worry
about the ingame and I was so focused on
the endgame that first time which I
think is really what set up all that
anxiety and depression that I went
through for a few years before you move
to New York you had a job and was it
organ donation
yes and this was like a dream job it
were rising in the company and you had
plans I don't know if you were saving it
for a house or you were doing some
things yes so I got in this job this was
right after Hurricane Katrina and I got
a job like right during that time and so
I never thought that organ donation
would become a passion point for me and
it did and so I worked the job and I was
doing extremely well within the company
and then all of a sudden they give me a
new position move me to New Orleans in
21 days they let me go like literally
walked me out of the front door with
security and changed the code it sounds
like it outside and I never felt like
that ever in my life and I thought this
was going to be my career job that I did
in tandem with making films but that's
not what the design was of it was about
did you tell them that you were a
filmmaker they knew so I know employers
get nervous about always being nervous
and I don't know I don't know why
necessarily either because I think
people have an outside passion actually
makes them better at their job because
it gives you something to look forward
to
as opposed to just coming back home
they're going back to work on Monday and
so they knew and they knew that I had
done some plays they knew that I had
some things going on but I just I'm not
filled with jealousy or interviewer if I
just didn't meet the corporate culture
that caused me to get fired but I got
fired and it took me a long time to
recover from that and so do you look
back on it now that it was almost a
blessing in some sense because your life
has taken many turns you went to New
York now you're here in LA yes I think
losing that job really was
the impetus that was needed for me to
kind of really start my career because
beforehand I mean when you have the
cushy job when you have the money your
passion is almost just inevitable you
take a back seat and so when I lost that
job I had saved up this money to buy a
home but now of course you can oh no job
and so I made my first feature film in
the way that I felt on that set the
moment that I said action I knew that's
what I was supposed to do and that
feeling is the feeling that has guided
me throughout my entire career like when
I had that feeling I know that it's
right I don't know that's what I'm
supposed to be doing so I look at it as
an ultimate blessing at the time but it
did take me through a lot of emotional
turmoil losing something that I felt
like I was supposed to have also - I'm
sure like losing trust in people having
been in a similar situation I know you
you do you lose faith in like a lot of
different things it's easy to get jaded
and so did did there were there things
that helped you out of that I think it
really just took time to be honest with
you for me to get from that place of
depression and not even know that I was
like even like depressed from having
lost their job I really honestly didn't
know that but I never really had a
clinical diagnosis but now that I'm
licking it and I saw the state of
depression means that you can't move
either way and so knowing that I was
there for so long I think it was really
time am I feeling that impassioned that
really helped me kind of get out of that
that place but I did lose faith in
people I did lose trust in people I kind
of still operate just like that I'm
having something taken away so violently
I knew the potential for that to happen
again it's always possible so there is a
part of me that is still extremely
guarded but I also know that I'm you
know things are aligned in order the way
that they're supposed to happen yeah
what if I switch should give to another
filmmaker on having a plan B or C or D
whatever cuz I think you know you had
this plan for this movie and then it
happens to a lot of filmmakers where
they think that's going to be the one to
just quote put them on the map and it it
takes several other
yeah I think one of the most difficult
things that happens to a filmmaker is
for them to have a plan for their
project and it not meet because then the
market success becomes something that
you can't control
well our job is simply now I realize
it's just to create that's what our job
is and the universe will do what the
universe is supposed to do so now when I
make projects or what I'm talking to
people or giving any type of advice I
always say just focus on creating and
everything that follows is what is
supposed to happen period point-blank
but if you say oh I'm gonna do this
project so that I can get into Sundance
and you made a project which is the gift
that's the hard part and you don't get
into Sundance then you feel like you
weren't successful and it's not the case
the success of your creativity was in
making the project everything after that
has nothing to do necessarily with you
or the project
it's just how that is supposed to move
throughout the world and you really
can't control that so when you had this
job you were planning on doing these
projects maybe on the weekends or you
you know balancing it around the
nine-to-five world well when I was
working at I thought that I was gonna
write this script and then Spike Lee was
gonna call I really thought one day he
would just hit me on the phone like do
you still have an arab script and I'm
like yes I do Spike Lee but that's just
not that's just not how it went in order
for me to have gotten to the place to
start creating I had to be in a space
that identified this is the only
opportunity that you had so it had to
happen that way in order for me to have
created that project and if it hadn't I
would have never found my purpose
because I had not made a film before
thinking I had just been writing I don't
even know that a short film existed I
went to a film festival in New Orleans
and I thought it was for like feature
films and I'm like of course I love
movies and then I'm like wait did that
just end in nine minutes I'm like wait I
didn't know it was a short film
and so that's how I got the thought oh
wait I could take a little bit of money
and I can do that and so that's where it
kind of came from
you